you may have recently heard about the
fda's new graphic cigarette warning
labels some of these pictures are
especially disturbing even revolting
no matter how you feel about smoking
what you may find even more revolting is
the idea that the fda has assumed the
power to take over a company's product
and use it to advertise their own agenda
whether consumers like it or not
or whether it works or not
these warning labels are from cigarette
packages in canada they've been on
cigarette packages there for the past 10
years teen cigarette smoking has
decreased in canada since 2001 but at
roughly the same rates as teen smoking
decreased in the us over the same period
without graphic warnings
according to a recent rasmussen reports
poll just 18 percent of americans think
these graphic warning labels will reduce
the number of smokers
88 percent of adults in the same poll
believe smokers are already aware of the
dangers speaking of danger why stop with
cigarettes all kinds of products come
with risks
imagine what warning labels the
government will require next
maybe this happy meal warning label
which will be accompanied by a toy heart
named cloggy
drive to work nothing will kill your
commute quite like this warning label
hitting the slopes for that vacay better
stay at work unless you want this dude's
haircut
and next time you toss back a cold one
with your buds be warned one of you
might turn into this guy
actually come to think of it when will
the government start issuing warning
labels on itself i wonder if we'd be
getting patted down by tsa if this
warning label had been on the cover of
the bill
that goes double for the patriot act
with this warning label thanks big bro
plastering this label on every voting
booth might prevent americans from
making the same mistakes over and over
again
next time you see those cigarette
warning labels remember the real danger
is a nanny state that restricts our
freedom while telling us it's all for
our own good